there's actually never been a better
time to be a designer than today I would
say and actually I'd like to call this
time that we're living in the age of
design IBM studies came out you might
know IBM does a big CEO study every two
years asking 5000 CEOs each time about
relevant topics of the time and in 2010
the main topic coming out of those
conversations was the most important
leadership quality CEOs seek is
creativity but what is creativity really
creativity is not a talent it's actually
a mindset creativity is now as important
in education as literacy we don't grow
into creativity we get educated out of
it as it is right now for lack of a
better solution we tend to grade
students on how few mistakes they make
if you're not prepared to make mistakes
you're not gonna ever come up with
anything original so if we basically
prime an entire generation on not making
mistakes
we're also priming them to really not
being creative or coming up with
original solutions creative is not the
same as design obviously what design can
really offer in this context is that it
can actually give creativity its place
design has toolbox has methods has a
process where there is a clear place and
time for creativity for divergent
thinking and so accordingly on
university level design is taught as a
very broad discipline these days a broad
range of people from very different
backgrounds from doctors to architects
to philosophers and it allows them to
use design as this common language as
this common platform by actually
agreeing on a set of methods on
set of tools and by actually valuing
things like being empathic being
collaborative being pragmatic
in fact driven and optimistic and that's
a very important set of skills and tools
that they use they're not everybody
should strive to be a designer but
everybody should strive to actually get
involved in design and we should really
start earlier occasionally we have the
fortune to actually work with some
schools like in this case with Punahou
secondary school in Hawaii it's a
private school the one that ex-president
Obama went to and we worked with them on
actually applying design methods into
their curriculum help them design before
they can teach designs so to speak and
then they went on and designed projects
for kids a third great design project
which is design your ideal toilet and
it's perfect for third graders they
learn that everything is designed it can
be redesigned they have the relevant
experience everybody's used a toilet and
it's not perfect for eight year old they
learn to take different points of input
and actually synthesize it
the point is design can actually teach a
lot more than just creativity that is
important whether you become a designer
or not